[Music]
did you know that 84% of My Little Pony
fans are male and we bet a lot of them
also love Disney if you love the two
worlds you're in for a real treat
because we're about to show you the most
amazing illustrations we have ever seen
rapunzel is really rockin My Little Pony
look don't forget to subscribe to the
things and give this video a thumbs up
today we're checking out ten Disney
Princesses reimagined as My Little Pony
Princess Jasmine My Little Pony is a
popular show for kids and teenagers this
resulted in a lot of interesting
illustrations that mix the world of
Disney with My Little Pony characters
let's start with arguably one of the
most beautiful Disney Princesses ever
Princess Jasmine is one of those
characters you just can't help to love
she's incredibly progressive stubborn
feisty and has a heart of gold so what
would happen if we mixed princess
Jasmine's look with a My Little Pony
character here's a very fabulous looking
Princess Jasmine as My Little Pony she
still has that bling on her and we love
her long dark hair Princess Jasmine
would perfectly fit in the magical pony
world as you know each Pony represents a
powerful element that relates to
friendship with that in mind which
element do you think Princess Jasmine
would represent would it be honesty or
would it be confidence we're sure she'd
have a lot to bring to the My Little
Pony story and she'd certainly add a
sarcastic tone to normal conversations
that's what you get from Princess
Jasmine but our next Disney Princess
would bring slightly different values do
you think the ponies would react well to
a frog that would turn back into a
Disney Princess inspired pony sounds
like our next character might be quite a
handful Princess Tiana Princess Tiana is
incredibly loyal and she knows she has
to work hard to realize her dreams and
never give up she looks sweet on the
outside but don't underestimate Princess
Tiana's values and spirit now imagine
what would Princess Tiana look like if
she became a My Little Pony character
she'd add a whole lot of
fabulous to the pony crew and we'd love
to see this look on the show this
illustration belongs to a deviantART
user inkling 97 and it is gorgeous
this version of Princess Tiana has
merged well with My Little Pony
and we love her green dress the necklace
and her dark hair do you think the lack
of opposable thumbs would get in the way
of Tiana's dreams of running a
restaurant
knowing this headstrong princess she'd
probably figure out how to make it all
work with her new features as a pony
wouldn't you love to see that story
Princess Tiana looking like a pony
trying to run a restaurant as if being a
frog wasn't difficult enough did you
ever notice that we've never seen
Tiana's hair being loose she always had
it tied back where the entire princess
in the frog movie and we loved that the
artist let her hair down for this My
Little Pony look speaking of hair
wait until you see brave and Rapunzel's
look in a few minutes
Belle another outspoken princess on our
list is Belle Belle is compassionate and
kind to everyone
how many Disney Princesses do you know
that are passionate bookworms we can
probably count them on one hand so it's
no wonder why Belle is such a popular
character this deviantART artist did an
amazing job putting Belle into the world
of my little pony this pony looks
focused reading her book but yet we can
see that this is Belle based on her
brown hair and her blue bow do you see
the detail on the book it looks like
Belle is reading her own Beauty and the
Beast story we can imagine she's get
along with many of the pony characters
including Twilight Sparkle who's also
quite a bookworm we bet the two would
have a thing or two to talk about the
Disney fan base still can't figure out
what Belle's actual favorite book is
remember the scene where she talks about
the far-off places daring sword fights
magic spells and a prince in disguise
something she's talking about Aladdin
while others just believe she is
foreshadowing what will happen to her
life story well there's a spot for Belle
on the My Little Pony show and we'd love
to see it all happen
Ariel you'd better get ready
because the Little Mermaid just became
the Little Pony and we love this look
why do these ponies look so fabulous in
any situation you could put them
underwater and they'd still manage to
rock the look we are in love with aerial
disguised as a character from My Little
Pony her red hair is looking even more
gorgeous if that's even possible ponies
as mermaids is such a popular concept
you can find several online dress-up
games and see what Ariel would look like
as a pony on your own but let's go back
to this the Little Pony character for a
moment we'd love to see what Sebastian
and flounder would look like as cartoon
ponies did you know that the color of
Ariel's fin was specifically blended by
the team behind the movie to complement
the existing colors of the sea nothing
quite like it was ever created before
and this particular color is named Ariel
after the Little Mermaid we'd love to
see more sea creatures in the original
My Little Pony show and it looks like
having a mermaid would be a perfect fit
which values do you think Ariel would
bring to the table we bet they would be
different from our next Disney Princess
and we can only hope these friendly
Ponies know how to walk on ice
Elsa okay Elsa it's time to let it go
and become a part of a brand new world
do you ever wonder what Elsa would look
like if she became a My Little Pony
character she's a feisty one much
spicier than Princess Jasmine or bell
but Elsa's love for her family is what
she would bring to the elements of
friendship check out this glittery
version of Elsa as a charming and feisty
looking pony
we love the gorgeous braids and the
sparkles on her pony tail did you know
that Elsa was originally supposed to be
a villain the co-directors of the movie
explained that Elsa was supposed to be a
villain and they changed her character
when they heard let it go
they also highlighted the importance of
Anna and Elsa having an emotional bond
this bond helped shape the movie into
the frozen you know today so if there's
anything Elsa would bring in the My
Little Pony world its family values and
the importance of how
an emotional bond with the person you
love and of course we can't forget her
amazing singing voice which belongs to
the talented idina menzel it's safe to
say Elsa would be able to out sing
practically any my little pony character
and we'd love to see it happen Snow
White let's just jump right into this
illustration because it's just so darn
cute
while other My Little Pony illustrations
so far all show the typical long-haired
look Snow White's version is sporting
cool short hair the red bow is still
there and the artist added a long blond
braid to the ponytail but what we love
are the three cute red apples next to
the ponytail Snow White is one of the
youngest Disney Princesses out there but
at just 14 she is one of the kindest and
loving princesses out there who else
could do such an amazing job at
befriending everyone they meet speaking
of Snow White
did you know Walt Disney was just a year
older than the Disney Princess herself
when he decided to retell the Snow White
and the Seven Dwarfs story the movie was
released in 1937 and it became an
instant success we loved the original
look of Snow White
but did you know that the dwarfs
eyebrows were modeled by Walt Disney's
eyebrows on the other hand Snow White's
charming look was based on a young
dancer marge champion do you think Marge
would approve of this version of Snow
White as a My Little Pony character
Cinderella
it looks like the fairy godmother casted
another bibbidi-bobbidi-boo spell and
turned Cinderella
into a My Little Pony princess we're not
sure why but this looks suit Cinderella
just as much as her original look
Cinderella is one of those classic
stories that will never go out of style
it brings important life lessons of
always being kind no matter what
believing in yourself and taking chances
this is exactly what Cinderella would
bring to the My Little Pony show and
she'd look fabulous doing it this Pony
is definitely rocking the Cinderella
hairstyle and we'd love to see more
details in this
transformation did you know that
Cinderella was the second most
successful Disney movie at the time and
the first to have its songs copyrighted
and published we'd love to see what some
of the other characters like Gus Gus
would look like as My Little Pony
characters do you notice the detail on
Cinderella's picture this Pony is even
wearing a glass slipper it would be very
interesting to see how that would play
out in the actual show with the My
Little Pony version of Cinderella still
be as graceful or what her glass
slippers give her even more trouble
she's not the only one with a special
feature just wait until you see our next
character Mulan is Mulan your favorite
Disney Princess wait until you see what
we have in store for you this version of
Mulan as a My Little Pony character
might just be the best one we've seen
yet Milan is known as being completely
independent and witty in our eyes she's
one of a unique Disney Princesses out
there
this illustration belongs to a
deviantART artist Benny Bing who created
one of the most amazing My Little Pony
characters she looks like she's ready to
take a stance and protect the people she
loves the most
which element of friendship do you think
Milan would bring in the series would it
be selfless or perhaps being determined
and going after what you want
we'd love to see these two worlds mix
this My Little Pony character is
different than the others we love that
the artist highlighted Milan's facial
features and gave a flower in her hair
unlike Tiana or Belle this illustration
comes with very little detail but we can
still easily see Milan's characteristics
shining through Milan is also one of the
most popular people's choices when it
comes to tattoos but we somehow can't
imagine anyone picking a tattoo of move
on as My Little Pony Merida we all know
Milan is a fierce character but is she
fiercer than this orange haired Disney
Princess who doesn't need a man to have
a popular story
we love Merida's unique look but we also
love this unique illustration of our
favorite character from brave as a
character from my
Little Pony if Milan is a free-spirited
Disney Princess
we think that Merida is a whole nother
level of free-spirited
her story is inspiring for anyone who is
looking for a strong female Disney
character as their role model this
version of Merida was created by a
deviantART user apostle Byrd who did an
amazing job at showing Merida as a very
fierce Pony as usual her hair is
absolutely out of control did you know
that Merida's hair was quite a problem
for the animators behind the movie
Merida was the first Disney Princess
that was able to show off her beautiful
hair this was a result of a long quest
to find that perfect animation software
that would enable the creators to create
slightly more realistic characters and
it worked even as a My Little Pony
character Merida looks ready to fight
for her rights speaking of hair there's
only one Disney character whose hair is
so fascinating we can't help but wonder
how did Disney managed to create such an
awesome look Rapunzel if there's a
Disney princess that would perfectly fit
in the world of My Little Pony its
Rapunzel the slightly naive but
headstrong 18 year old is one of the
quirkiest princesses out there don't
forget she uses a frying pan to fight
off anyone that stands in her way the
biggest friendship element she would
bring to the My Little Pony crew is love
and we agree because we love her magical
pony look did you know that the animator
behind tangled hired his daughter who
then created Rapunzel's room he
explained that when she was younger she
was already interested in painting by
the time tangled was in production his
daughter was so good he ended up just
hiring her to create the look of
Rapunzel's room but it's not just
Rapunzel's room that catches your eye as
you're watching the movie her 70 foot
long hair is fascinating
while Merida's hair was developed using
a new animation software the animators
behind Rapunzel still use the old
techniques but it's safe to say that the
talented team managed
to do the impossible to create
Rapunzel's long hair the team used 70
foot long cloth and dangled it out of
the balcony to see how it would move we
can imagine why this my little pony
Rapunzel character doesn't have her
signature long haired look but that
doesn't mean we don't love it which was
your favorite Disney Princess My Little
Pony character let us know in the
comments and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up for more Disney
mania check out 10 Disney Princesses
reimagined as monsters see you next time
[Music]